russia calls them nazis ukraine calls
them heroes by any name these soldiers
are now prisoners of war the kremlin
says almost 700 more ukrainian troops
left the azov style steel plant
wednesday some only barely walking
hobbling or carried out on stretchers
video from russia's defense ministry
claims to show injured soldiers being
held 40 kilometers east of mariupol
they gave me first aid and food i can't
complain says this man we don't know if
he was speaking under duress russia
isn't saying what will happen to them
next and has not agreed to ukraine's
wishes for a prisoner swap
the status of one of the russian troops
being held by ukraine is clear
vadim
pleaded guilty to murdering a ukrainian
civilian in the first war crimes trial
of the conflict
he allegedly shot a 62 year old on a
bicycle from a stolen car the dead man's
widow watching in court
meanwhile nato ambassadors from finland
and sweden formally submitted
applications to join the alliance the
security interests of all allies have to
be taken into account
and we are determined to work through
all issues
for all issues read turkey's issue
president erdogan again threatening to
block the nordic nations unless they
stop harboring kurdish separatists we
have also a
security concerns that they have been
supporting
terrorist organizations u.s president
joe biden says he thinks a deal will be
hammered out i'm not going to turkey but
i think we're going to be okay biden has
also suggested the u.s will follow the
uk in guaranteeing the security of
finland and sweden while their
applications are being considered
redmond shannon global news london